otherwise we are in recess until we hear
from the jury in their final words on
the most highly charged U.S Civil Rights
case in decades prosecutors told jurors
to trust their eyes but for
the defendant's actions pushing him down
George Floyd have died that day
is it drugs
he just miraculously derive a die of a
drug overdose in that time maybe it was
the tailpipe maybe it was his enlarged
heart
maybe not use your common sense
use your common sense
believe your eyes what you saw you saw
what the jury saw was the same nine and
a half minutes the world saw of then
Minneapolis Police Officer Derek Chauvin
kneeling on George Floyd's neck until
paramedics carried off his lifeless body
in a case that started with an allegedly
fake twenty dollar bill and ended with
protests and riots across the United
States prosecutors said the evidence
proved Chauvin used excessive force
choked the life out of Floyd and refused
to render Medical Care even after he
showed no pulse
[Music]
and at the time of causing the death the
defendant committed or was attempting an
assault in the third degree
and that's been proved Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt
with those being proved in the venue
right second degree felony murder the
defendant is guilty
the defense argued that Chauvin held
Floyd face down just as he was trained
to
was putting Mr Floyd eminently dangerous
act we've heard a lot about the prone
position
consider just the basic prone position
people sleep in the prom position people
suntan in the prone position people get
massages in the prone position the prong
position in and of itself is not an
inherently dangerous Act
a prom position during restraint is not
an inherently dangerous Act
it is routinely trained and used by the
Minneapolis Police Department
defense lawyer Eric Nelson blamed
bystanders for chauvin's failure to
administer life-saving CPR saying he
felt unsafe
and hoping to give jurors enough
Reasonable Doubt for an acquittal he
offered a broad array of alternative
theories for Floyd's death heart trouble
drugs even car exhaust
we have to analyze this case from the
perspective of a reasonable police
officer at the precise moment with the
totality of the circumstances when it
comes to the use of force chauvin's fate
Now lies in the hands of the jury which
is in isolation until they can render a
unanimous verdict one reason for
sequestering them is to make sure they
don't hear news of protesters demanding
chauvin's conviction but with
demonstrations across the country it's
not clear they won't be able to hear
protests from where they're deliberating
deliberations can range dramatically in
length in 1992 it took seven days for
jurors and the police beating of Rodney
King to find four officers not guilty
three years later jurors took less than
four hours to declare O.J Simpson not
guilty of murder for Chauvin and for
residents of Minneapolis and cities
across the U.S that weight will be
filled with anxiety and fear for what
comes next John hendren Al Jazeera
Minneapolis